This video is brought to you by
squarespace.
Whether you need a domain,
website or online store,
make it with squarespace.
Hey wisecrack jared here today we're
talking about an Amazon and she has
nothing to do with an endangered plant
species or free two day shipping.
Wonder woman wasn't just the mega box
office hit of the summer.
The film and its eponymous hero have
become one of 2017 biggest cultural
icons and surprise.
We have something to say about it.
Now some have called areas a pretty lack
luster villain,
but his conflict with Diana is pretty
interesting compared to most superhero
villains who want to just rule the world
or ruled world or rule as guard or rule
the universe and part of what makes this
Greek God family drama so cool is that
aries doesn't just blindly hate Diana.
There clash over the nature and fate of
humanity is well pretty philosophical,
so get ready to be lassoed by the truth
in this wise crack addition on the
philosophy of wonder woman and cue the
sirens.
One of the central conflicts of wonder
woman is do humans deserve to be saved?
This makes sense.
Since the titular characters from an
island of warrior women who exist solely
to save humans from destruction at the
hand of aries,
the God of war.
But as it turns out,
when you've lived in a tropical paradise
with no boys allowed for a couple of
millennia,
you might decide that humans aren't
really worth the effort.
View's great demand to be Justin Wise,
strong and passionate.
That was a story.
Diane,
much of Diana's struggle is wrapped up
in the question of what it means to save
people.
She waivers between a sense of duty,
a sense of caring and a moment of great
a apathy they done deserve our help.
It's not about meanwhile Erin is fully
committed to the belief that humans suck
a fat bag of popsicles and deserve not
only abandonment but also to die
painfully via chemical weapons.
Area's developed a weapon.
The worst ever device.
Diana's big hero statement of the film
is in response to areas his claim that
she responds,
it's not about deserve,
it's not what you believe.
We believe that line is confusing is,
but instead of dismissing it as bad
writing and good old wise cracking and
fashion,
let's pull it apart.
Now before we get the Diana,
we have to understand what she's
responding to.
Areas is belief that humans are
worthless and can't have nice things.
Aries is claiming the film has two
parts,
one that humans deserve to be punished
and to that they don't deserve Diana's
help.
Right?
The first one is a question of something
called retribute of justice.
Basically the theory that argues that
people who do bad things should go to
jail.
So what informs areas as retribute of
mission to destroy humanity?
He believes that humans are by nature
evil
and always will be weak,
cruel,
selfish,
and capable of the greatest harvest.
This is an essential list view of human
nature that humanity has inherit
properties that make them what they are,
so people are doomed to be useless
assholes forever.
So it makes sense why you'd want to get
rid of them.
Areas.
His claim is bolstered by the summer of
humanities actions over the last couple
thousand years and that time humans have
done a lot.
They genocide it.
A bunch of people destroyed the
environment and made this Logan Paul
Guy,
famous
mankind ruin bid day by day.
So that's the first part of areas.
His claim.
Now for the second one,
one that is much more central to Diana
and the film's Arc,
the question of who deserves to be
saved,
even if it's from their own kind.
This is distributive justice in aries
calculation being saved from death is
not something that one is entitled to.
It's something that is distributed based
on merit as shown by the actions of the
individual or in this case the actions
of the groups spanning three plus
Millennia.
This seems to be a pretty common idea
among mortals.
Diane,
his mother Hippolyta tells her,
do not deserve you.
This all reflects one popular approach
to distribute of justice called desert
theory,
which are used that people deserve
things,
jobs,
money,
awards based on their actions rather
than on their needs or the benefit it
would bring to society.
Now,
although Diana stays generally
consistent in her desire to help
humanity,
the logic behind this choice develops
and changes throughout the film.
And while we see people justifying their
actions with distributed or Richard,
you'd have frameworks,
wonder woman goes a different route.
Diana is raised to believe that the
amazons have a sacred duty to stop aries
and defend the world.
So when she sets out for Europe,
she's not doing it because she believes
humans deserve anything.
It's because she has a moral obligation
to help.
This moral obligation carries her
through most of the film.
Even as she watches British general send
soldiers to their debt,
you should be ashamed and Germans taking
villagers as slaves.
But at some point she realizes that
people suck and it wasn't totally areas
his fault that they were bayoneting each
other.
They can stop fighting.
Why are they still,
cause I've picked up sensor duty was to
defend the world from aries and not
humans acting on their own accord.
She's not really sure where her moral
obligations lie anymore.
All of a sudden her mom's wise words
sound a whole lot wiser.
And my thought was right not to serve
yet.
Diana's faced with a crisis of
conscious.
She's no longer bound by duty and her
knowledge of human atrocities leader to
the conclusion that humans do not merit
her help as a matter of justice either.
Although Diana makes it less obvious
than areas does.
She's also motivated by a kind of
essential ism.
Let's call this the battle of essential
isms.
Arie says,
humans are inherently evil.
Diana says they're inherently good.
While aries never abandoned his
essential ism,
Diana does,
when she discovers humans can be dick
bags all on their own.
We don't see too much more of this
crisis,
but all is resolved by the time she
says.
At first it might sound like she
believes in the love of Steve Trevor,
but that doesn't make a ton of sense,
so let's give her a little more credit
than that.
It's only at the end that it becomes
clear to her and to us why saving people
is the right thing to do.
What differentiates Diana at the end
from someone like Captain America is
that she realizes it's not her duty to
help people.
She just wants to because she loves the
shit out of humanity.
Even though that might sound like a
Saccharin care bear cop out,
it's not while she leaves behind the
ideas of duty and deserving wonder woman
taps into a totally different ethical
approach.
That's pretty unique in the superhero
genre.
Hair.
Epic's care ethics focuses on the
relationship between the person who is
caring for someone and the person who
was terrible.
For a good example,
a parent who loves their child,
even if that child is terrible,
or Logan.
Paul,
unlike most traditional approaches to
ethics,
Kara ethics rejects universalized
principles for how to make judgments or
how to act.
Everything is contextualized within the
given relationship.
However,
certain practices are pretty important,
like respect,
empathy,
and attention to the needs of others.
Sometimes these relationships are on
equal footing,
but not always.
Wonder woman is not are equal.
So it's more like a person caring for a
perfect puppy,
just like you're not born with an
obligation to care for.
A dog wonder woman knowingly chooses to
enter a relationship of care with people
who will never be able to entirely
reciprocate and maybe don't deserve it.
She isn't pursuing a defined goal other
than making the world a better place or
holding firm to certain universal
principles like that man's idea that
killing is always wrong or captain
America's belief in the American way.
As long as you forget that whole hail
hydra thick,
she is responding as needed to the needs
of those.
She cares for him.
At the end of the film,
Diana's relationship rejects a kind of
distributed or retributive justice and
instead she makes a choice to love them,
but then I glimpsed the darkness that
lives within their lines and learn that
inside every one of them there will
always be both and now I know only love
can truly save the world.
Diana's belief in love isn't a
meaningless platitudes.
It's a declaration of her commitment to
a particular state of mind and action
that guides her decisions as a hero.
This is clear in her decision not to
kill Dr poison despite her being a war
criminal and also really creepy
is the perfect example.
Pull off these humans.
I'm not going to want to be up y'all so
proper hear that
although we would be a bit of a stretch
to say that wonder woman enters a
relationship of care with colonel
mustard gas just because she decides not
to throw a literal tank at her.
It's indicative of Diana's change in
mindset.
This is visually paralleled by doctor
poisons,
mass flying off piece by piece as the
wind uncovers her true,
scarred ugly self.
There's a very obvious metaphor and
Diana recognizes the complex nature and
individual differences of humans.
Everything you say so much
more,
even though by most calculations,
Dr poison probably deserves to die.
Diana rejects the concept of deserving
and by extension rejects the desert
theory of justice that aries is so fond
of every superhero has his or her or its
reasons for blowing stuff up and saving
the day.
Wonder woman defines Diana's ethos of
care and solidifies her role in the
Justice League for many franchises to
come,
but it also draws out a frequent theme
in comics.
The worthiness of the People Save Gotham
doesn't deserve Batman and America
doesn't deserve Steve Rogers.
Wonder woman raises a question that we
don't usually hear.
Does humanity deserve to be saved at
all?
And even if they don't,
should we save them?
Anyway,
thanks for watching you guys.
He's looking to lasso up a beautiful
professional website to promote your
work.
Squarespace's got your covered.
Using the offer code wise crack,
you can hit over to squarespace today to
get 10% off your first purchase with a
wealth of gorgeous designer templates on
an easy to use all in one platform.
Squarespace makes it easy for you to
create an eye catching fully functional
website for your art or business with
zero coding knowledge required.
Check out squarespace.com
for a free trial.
And when you're ready to launch your
site,
go to squarespace.com/wise
crack and use the offer code wise crack
to save 10% off your first purchase of a
website or domain.
Thanks to squarespace for sponsoring
this video,
and thank you all for watching.
Remember to hit that subscribe button
and ring that bell.
Catch y'all.
Next time.
He's.